à ribeauvillé sur le domaine louis sip
une équipe de vendangeurs parcours les
vignes attirés par les quelques semaines
de travail proposé par le viticulteur on
y trouve des étudiants des passionnés
des travailleurs saisonniers ou
simplement des demandeurs d'emploi parmi
ceux là mélissa la jeune femme est
allocataire du rsa et va pour cette
saison additionner son salaire de
vendangeuse et la location l'occasion
pour elle d'augmenter ponctuellement ses
revenus et de faire à nouveau des
projets c'est bien pour nous est de ceux
qui l'ont accusé les pro gens qui
veulent passer le permis ou ceux qui
veulent s'acheter une voiture ou des
choses comme ça ça s'arrête quoi alors
qu'avant et coupé le rsa est révélé bon
choix
depuis 2018 le département du haut-rhin
permettent aux allocataires des minima
sociaux de cumuler revenus des vendanges
et rsa
derrière ce dispositif l'idée de
permettre aux chômeurs de longue durée
de trouver un emploi temporaire sans les
pénaliser au portefeuille
un allocataire touche autour d'eux une
personne seule autour de 400 450 euros
pour le mois
et si elle travaillait ne serait ce que
1 ou 2 jours cet argent gagné et
défalqué du revenu donc il n'est pas
intéressant de faire un travail alors
que derrière le revenu diminue et là
c'est le contraire et on a beaucoup de
personnes qui du coup sont retournés
dans le système en dix ans mais nous on
est preneur puisque bas il faut aussi
mettre dans la réalité du quotidien
la nécessité d'avoir de l'argent pour
vivre pour les employeurs les
bénéficiaires du dispositif sont des
salariés comme les autres il n'ya pas
d'incitation financière allait recruter
mais chez les cip
on a la fibre sociale autant que
vigneronne quand on termine les
vendanges etc on a rentré nos kilos de
raisins qu'on a nos mou qui fermente de
pouvoir se dire qu'on n'a pas seulement
rentrer du kilo mais on a aussi permis à
quelques personnes de retrouver un peu
de dignité un peu de confiance en elle
on se dit que ça vaut le coup de faire
du vin ça vaut le coup de faire du vin
de terroir parce que ça a un sens et ça
c'est important nous pour nous c'est
important cet aspect cette année ils
sont déjà plus d'une soixantaine à
s'être signalé à la caisse d'allocations
familiales pour bénéficier du dispositif
qui sera étendu à la récolte des
16 ainsi que des asperges